all right welcome back everybody so we
want to finish up by going to Los
Angeles where a restructured jury panel
continues deliberations in the rape
trial of actor Danny Masterson the
former That 70s Show star faces
accusations from three women all former
members of the Church of Scientology who
practiced alongside Masterson all three
testified during trial claiming the
assaults took place at Masterson's
Hollywood Hills Home prosecutors argued
that the religious group's power and
influence prevented the victims from
speaking out sooner now Masterson didn't
take the stand but his defense team
argued that the Acts were consensual and
that the accuser's stories were
inconsistent now the jury originally
came back deadlocked but the judge
ordered them to come back after the
Thanksgiving break this gave the panel
nine whole days away from the courthouse
as of Monday two members of the original
jury panel tested positive for covid-19
and two alternates have taken their
place so the question is is this going
to derail the course of deliberations
well let's talk about it Terry I'll
start with you there two new jurors
sitting in they're giving their two
cents do you think ultimately this is
going to help or slow things down even
more oh it's definitely going to slow it
down and I think it could put the whole
case at risk here I've often thought
that the alternates should sit in on the
deliberations from the very beginning
and then not take place in the vote but
that's not the way it's done they are
kicked out and they don't come in until
they are needed but the problem there is
when you start all over you might miss
some of the information that you talked
about originally and it's just not as
clean plus the fact that they were out
for that long over the Thanksgiving
break you know some of them saw some of
the news and you know that they talked
about the case and at the end of the day
there could be a mistrial if that comes
out so yes I think this is going to
derail the whole case but we also don't
know if those jurors that were removed
ultimately were the ones that were
keeping up the deadlock jury right Brian
I mean what do you think the issues are
that the jury's wrestling with well two
things first to your point we don't know
what the deadlock was let's say for
example it was nine to three to convict
well maybe the two jurors coming in were
part of the nine or part of the three
maybe it's seven to five maybe it's ten
or sorry eleven to one we don't know but
the main issue I think is going to be
credibility of the alleged victims here
because of that extra aspect of the
church and Scientology as to when they
reported how much influence the church
had on them whether or not their stories
were consistent as the defense argued I
think the new addition of these two
jurors along with these issues of
credibility is what's holding up this
jury yeah by the way credit to Brian
great math lawyers usually not great at
math that was very impressive I don't
think I would have been able to do that
all right I'm really good with 12.
Switching gears now to a new move in the
case against two parents accused of
being partially responsible for a school
shooting that killed four students
Jennifer and James crumbly were supposed
to go to trial in January but a Michigan
Supreme Court judge sent the case back
to the state court of appeals James and
Jennifer are each facing four charges of
involuntary manslaughter in connection
with the Oxford High School shooting the
prosecution says the crumblies allowed
their son access to a weapon when there
were signs he could commit acts of
violence the gunman himself pleaded
guilty to 24 counts out of Long Island
New York involving one Suffolk County
Police Officer known to the community as
the baby whisperer on Saturday morning
Sergeant John Eric Negron helped save a
newborn baby's life with assistance from
his fellow officers Owen Anthony
Maldonado entered the world in his
family's living room nearly three weeks
early now this is Sergeant negron's
fifth baby delivery in five years in
2017 he became a Godfather to the third
baby he delivered that child had stopped
breathing due to an umbilical cord
wrapped around the neck and that same
year the baby Whisperer made a delivery
on the side of the road with help from
another officer Sergeant Negron told ABC
7 quote I thought that my child
birthdays were over when I became a
sergeant this year and I guess the
record lives on we'll see how many more
we can take it to unbelievable an
obstetrician officer in another word